Think about the times where you have felt most connected to God.
Where was it? For many people, myself included, it's taken place on the top of a
mountain. There's just something about being in nature, higher than normal, away
from distractions, that we feel the presence of God.
There's something powerful and spiritual about being on the top of a mountain.
Interestingly, the great monotheistic religions all have traditions of a
formative experience for their founder on a mountaintop.
Take Judaism. Moses, arguably the most important prophet of the Old Testament,
both saw God face to face and received the law on a mountaintop.
In Islam, Muhammad, the founding prophet, claimed to receive the revelation
from the angel Gabriel, which he wrote down as verses or surahs.
In the Quran. And Jesus gave some of his most important teaching
on the Mount of Olives.
Like naturalism and pantheism, monotheism offers answers to our four big worldview
questions. And the first question is, what is real?
Now in naturalism, you'll remember that only physical things exist.
On pantheism, all is divine. But on monotheism, there's both
physical and non-physical things.
There are material and immaterial entities.
So rocks, dirt, and trees and other physical things are very real.
But there's also a spiritual realm that includes God, angels, demons,
and the soul.
The second worldview question is, what is man?
Rather than seeing man as the result of this blind, purposeless evolutionary process
as naturalism claims, or a part of the oneness of the universe as pantheism claims,
monotheism states that we are the purposeful creation of a loving and personal God.
And we uniquely reflect his character and image.
The third worldview question is, what happens at death?
According to naturalism, humans simply face extinction.
According to pantheism, we go through some kind of reincarnation until we enter the
oneness of the universe. But on monotheism, when we die, we face judgment based upon
God's standards and how we lived our lives.
And then for eternity, we either go to heaven or we go to hell.
The fourth worldview question is, what is the basis for right and wrong?
And unlike in pantheism and naturalism, on monotheism, morality is not
a human construct. Rather, morality comes from either the characteristics of God,
the character, or the commands of God.
So there is a source outside of us that we are accountable to.
We don't get to decide what is right and wrong, but we do get to decide if we're
going to follow it.
Essentially, monotheism says we are the purposeful creation of one God.
And our lives now and for eternity depend upon how we respond to this God.
Now when we talk about monotheism, we're kind of talking about God in the abstract.
The question is, has this one God made himself known?
Has this God stepped into creation and revealed his plan and purpose for
mankind?